As leaders,
I see people getting caught up all the times in little things that will not
affect the outcome unless they let it.
So I see some white belt blow them in the chain of command.
It's going all crazy.
Grabbing their sleeve and this leader on the top like gets concerned about it
and put time and effort into something that doesn't matter whether it's a little
personality rub,
a little keigo uprising.
It's should we do it this way or should we do it that way?
Doesn't matter.
That's a little sleeve grab.
It doesn't matter.
And I see people getting caught up on things that don't matter all the time.
And what I've realized is it's something that I figured out a long time ago.
I don't know when,
but a long time ago I figured out,
you know what?
That thing doesn't matter.
I'm not going to worry about it.
That thing matters.
I'm going to focus on that thing and that makes,
that makes a big a big,
big,
big difference.
It's,
it's leadership capital because if I'm investing my leadership capital and
getting your hand off my sleeve or trying to do it my way instead of your way or
trying to keep your ego in check if that's what I'm investing my leadership
capitalists,
I have nothing left to invest in the thing that's actually matters.
Just like if you're a black belt in someone guys grabbing your sleeve and you
focus on pulling that and off your whole time you're going to waste energy and
maybe even give a position cause your,
cause you were focused on something that did not matter.
So it is important to realize and to learn to differentiate between things that
don't matter and things that do matter.
Yeah
and in order to tell the difference between those two things,
you have to be able to detach
and step back.
And obviously this is the same thing,
not just with Jujitsu,
not just with leadership,
not just with combat.
Cause it's the same thing in combat.
You're going to have things that don't,
things aren't happening on the battlefield that don't matter.
Little,
hey guys,
move in here instead of there.
That doesn't matter.
Oh,
this guy's moving there so it doesn't matter.
The enemy is doing this.
Okay,
it doesn't matter.
Oh wait,
the end we did that thing that matters or one of my guys did this thing that
matters.
So how do you learn to discriminate between the two?
You have to be able to detach from it.
That's what you have to do.
You have to be able to detach and
okay,
if you,
if you don't learn to detach,
you're going to constantly get tripped up on things that don't really matter.
And I'll tell you,
the more,
the better you get,
the less things matter.
The better you get.
The last things matter.
And the better you get,
the more the more important things matter.
Hmm.
So you,
you end up just wasting no energy on things that don't matter.
And focusing all your energy on things that actually matter.
And this is the difference,
man.
This is how you win in Jujitsu.
This is how you win as a leader.
This is how you win in combat.
And this is truly how you win in life.
Think about all the things you don't,
what you used to talk about a lot.
You haven't done it in a while.
You just talk about distractions now.
Things can distract you.
That's totally true.
That's what I'm talking about.
The things that distract you from what actually matters.
So you have to,
you have to figure out how to detach from those things.
I was doing some reading as is per norm.
There's a guy named Keith Douglas.
He was a British soldier,
World War II.
He's kind of a bad ass.
He was stuck in an administrative position in October of 1942 during the second
battle of El Alamein.
And so he was stuck in this administrative position,
so he just went AWOL and went to the front line and join the fight and got after
it.
And one of the things.